what's your opinion on going to tanning
salons in the winter to boost vitamin d
you know i have actually been thinking
about this very question have you yeah i
totally have which is that given the
role vitamin d seems to play in terms of
uh preserving health or maybe the way to
say it is that vitamin d
deficiency plays in making one
vulnerable to communicate communicable
diseases in the winter
that there is an argument for
uh
i don't know if it's tanning beds or
rooms or whatever that would
create vitamin d and make people
healthier but it's a you know it's a
pretty good reason to
to do that
so yeah i don't know i've never looked
into tanning beds um i don't know the
you know sort of uva uvb uvc ratios and
um right what so what but you know you
and i of course land in the same place
then which is there ought to be tanning
beds that are tuned to minimize the risk
and maximize the vitamin d creation but
the chances that they're likely to be
the ones that exist for people to get um
winter tans
indoors
seems small to me right on the other
hand if people understood the connection
between vitamin d deficiency and ill
health then
the market might create such things
for one thing it's got to be
i don't want to say it has to be but
it's probably pretty close to trivial to
add a setting that would allow you to
dial in the nature of the tanning device
so that it gave you the optimal thing
for whatever you were trying to
accomplish well i guess one other thing
that i don't know that's relevant to
this question is um
whether or not the vitamin d that would
be generated from being exposed to
artificial sun
um
you know how how comparable are these
three things the vitamin d generated by
exposure to the actual sun the vitamin d
generated by exposure to an artificial
sun and the vitamin d encountered by
taking a supplement and it's those last
two categories that um you know that are
maybe what you would be
um
constrained to in the winter and in
general as we write in the book and as
as you know of me i'm not a
fan of supplements i would rather get my
stuff from my food and my activities and
um engaging as uh humans have typically
engaged with the world but vitamin d
seems like a supplement as far as we can
tell is quite effective
quite effective uh quite low risk
and so you know if that is true
why not just take the supplement
why not just take the supplement well i
guess
i mean look i think we have an analogous
question with respect to something like
coffee
okay that basically
because you've got a complex system that
has detectors on it or in the case of
vitamin d it has synthesizers in the
skin
that there's really just a question of
you know do you want to do you want to
get that update by plugging in an
ethernet cable or do you want to get
that update over the wi-fi and
the coffee
can wake you up in the morning
and you take it in through your gut
and
the same thing would happen if you
stared into
a cool spectrum light as soon as you got
up
right
is there a reason to prefer one of these
i'm sure there's a spectrum of reasons
but it's not obvious to me that the
priority should go to the through the
gut route uh rather than the the
over-the-air route
well and this is i think then um
i think you're agreeing with me in this
particular case then
that to my surprise i find evidence that
vitamin d supplementation is actually
effective and not particularly costly
and super easy compared to oh i'm gonna
have to go spend an hour a week or
whatever it might be in a tanning bed
like why why wouldn't you if if there is
similar efficacy if as it seems vitamin
d supplementation
is actually effective and taking it in
the way that our ancestors have
generating vitamin d the way their
ancestors have generating it have
generated it
doesn't have as many
different effects as many other things
do
then you know i i would always prefer to
be generating my vitamin d out in the
sun
but then
then if i'm if i'm restricted from that
because of the season
and it's a you know a tanning bed that's
been tuned to just right which may or
may not exist in the world yet versus a
pill right in this case i'd prefer the
pill actually yeah i i i agree on the
other hand you could imagine
um
you know a tanning bed that was tuned so
it did little harm
gave you some tan
and
created vitamin d that would be an
attractive option to people you're
saying i look pale i'm
not saying anything like that darling um
i'm i'm just saying it's it's not
obvious to me that the pill is the one
to bet on for being uh
to having the fewest
arbitrary consequences
um
no i mean conservatively it would be the
opposite the assumption would be
um the opposite i would think
[Music]
you